ضاقت المستشفيات او ما تبقى منها في مناطق
الزلزال بالمصابين الذين توزعوا هنا وهناك
فالزلزال الذي ضرب 10 مدن رئيسيه وضع حملا
ثقيلا على القطاع الصحي اما بنى مدمره او
بسعه لا تستطيع خدمه جميع سكان تلك المدن
لا يوجد مستشفى في الحي الذي اسكن فيه
واقرب واحد لي مليء بالمصابين جراء
الزلزال لهذا لا يمكنهم تقديم المساعده
لاشخاص مثلي عبء طال الناجين من الزلزال
الذين بقوا في العرائدون تدفئه ووسط بيئه
غير صحيه انا واطفالي مصابون بالانفلونزا
لم نستطع الاعتناء بانفسنا بسبب الزلزال
هذه السفينه الحربيه القادره على انزال
دبابات من فئه بيرقدار تحولت الى مستشفى
مؤقت لتقديم المساعده الطبيه لمواطني
مدينه اسكندرون والمناطق المحيطه بها ساعه
المستشفى العائم قرابه 300 سرير وتحتوي
على غرف للاطباء وغرف جراحه وفحص المرضى
بكافه التخصصات الدقيقه والحيويه بمعدات
واجهزه طبيه لكافه الحالات ومنذ كارثه
الزلزال تمكن المستشفى العائم من تقديم
الخدمات العلاجيه لاكثر من 2000 محتاج لها
واسرهم